one last George Santos slash Anthony
devolder story George Santos is now uh
the target of three ethics complaints
over his campaign spending his campaign
fundraising and his financial disclosure
Business Insider and Brian Metzger have
a piece about this uh the left-leaning
advocacy group and citizens united is
going to be filing three ethics
complaints against George Santos
alleging campaign Finance violations and
adding to a number of other complaints
the group's complaint with the
Department of Justice argues Santos
violated the Ethics in Government Act
but not by not only filing a required
Financial disclosure almost a year late
but also most likely making several
omissions related to assets he's
purported to hold the complaint with the
office of congressional ethics argues
that he violated federal law by
soliciting campaign contributions in
exchange for attending a swearing-in
event on Capitol grounds last month his
team advertised round-trip bus tickets
from New York to DC a lunch and
attendance at Santos is swearing in and
a tour of the capital if you donate at
least 100 bucks federal law prevents the
use of official resources in connection
with campaign activity huh that's
disappointing isn't it the group's
complaint with the FEC focuses on a
purported seven hundred thousand dollar
personal loan that he made to his Camp
campaign that the group says either came
from a shell company or was a prohibited
corporate contribution
uh you can read about the details of
each of each of these complaints this is
you know this is a very important guy at
the end of the day George Santos is the
first person to ever walk across the
Pacific Ocean he can turn Mountain Dew
into liquid silver and obviously I'm
kidding and this is a very very bad
start for George Santos it is
increasingly clear that the Republican
party is panicking but only because it
looks bad they don't actually care about
this guy being a liar McCarthy has still
not even made any criticisms it appears
as though there's some kind of you know
I'm not saying it's a illegal bribery
but just a sort of quid pro quo Santos
pledged to support McCarthy for speaker
and McCarthy may be pledged not to
suggest that Santos should resign that
at least seems to be holding true for
the time being we'll see if it changes
but Republicans only care about this
insofar as it's damaging their
credibility I hope Santos resigns let's
hope by Monday he's gone all of of these
clips will be on our Instagram which you
can find by searching Instagram for
David packman show
the science tells us that one of the
best ways to get consistent deep sleep
is lowering your core body temperature
when your body stays cooler at night
you're more comfortable and your sleep
is better our sponsor sleep me is the
home of chili sleep the customizable
climate controlled sleep solutions that
can improve your sleep by keeping you
cooler at night there are three
different chili sleep systems there's
the uler the cube and the new Doc Pro
with double the cooling power all three
systems are water-based temperature
controlled mattress toppers that fit
over your existing mattress to provide
you with your ideal sleep temperature
you can go as cool as 55 degrees you can
go really hot if you want I keep mine at
60 beautiful temperature for me
don't wake up hot and sweaty chilly
sleep keeps me asleep all night it feels
great I didn't know it was possible to
love sleeping even more than I already
did go to sleep.me slash Pacman to learn
more and get 25 off your new chili Sleep
System click the link below to start
staying cool at night